the people in the music industry will
ruin someone's life and lose no sleep
over it and it takes a certain type of
person to do that right they will they
will shoot someone in the head watch
them drop dead on the floor turn to
their assistant and say what's for lunch
and not think twice about what they've
just done they will they will take an
artist who's a 20 year old kid with
dreams they will ruin his career because
of whatever reason they want to and they
will not think about it again when they
leave the room like for people like us
if if you hurt someone's feelings or I
love people I'm a people person if I do
something wrong to someone
uh it bugs me right the the people
leading the music industry it doesn't
bug them they could literally ruin
someone's life and then never ever ever
think about it again yeah so they think
of artists as cattle basically yeah I
think it's more than I I think it's
beyond just money because there are very
talented very good people who don't get
any play on the radios or in the music
industry and